توجه الان الى علي صمودي الصحفي وهو موجود
معنا من داخل مستشفى ابن سينا في جنين
مرحبا علي من جديد ما الذي توفر لديك من
تفاصيل عن هذه
العمليه نعم الان ونحن في المستشفى نتابع
وصول الاهالي و لمتابعه ومعرفه حقيقه ما
حدث بانتظار تصريح او بيان رسمي من
المستشفى مكبرات الصوت في مدينتي ومخيم
الجنين الانن مع الشهداء الشهداء محمد
جلامه والشقيق باسل ومحمد غزاوي باسل هو
جريخ تعرض للاصابه قبل فتره ويعاني من
اعاقه وسلل ولا يمكنه الحركه وشقيقه محمد
هو الذي كان يرعى لكن مصادر المقاومه قالت
لنا ان الشبان الثلاثه ينتمون الى
المقاومه في مخيم جينين محمد جيلاني ينتمي
الى كتائب الشهيد عز السلام الجناحي
العسكري بحك حماد وباسل الغزاوي وشفه محمد
ب سميان بكتيبه في جنين التابعه لسراي
القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي الان المقاومه تهدد وتوعد
الاحتلال بالرد على هذه الجريمه المعلومات
كما قال لنا الشهود محمد ان وحدات
اسرائيليه خاصه تسللت في ساعه مبكره في
البدايه تقدم ثلاثه من الاشخاص من افراد
الوحدات الذين كانوا يتخفون بذي اطباء
دخلوا الى المستشفى ويبدو انهم ه هؤلاء
الذين نفذوا عمليه الاغتيال بعد ذلك دخل
الى المستشفى ثمانيه مستعرضين على الاقل
كانوا يرتدون اشكال او يتفون باشكال
مختلفه احدهم في زي فتاه اخر كان يحمل
عربه صغيره لطفل بيديه وثالث كان يقود
عربه مصاب
وكانه مصاب او مريض ويقوده الى داخل
المستشفى دخلوا داخل المستشفى وتوجهوا الى
الصابق الثالث كسر الرجال حيث قاموا
باعدام الشبان او الش الشبان الثلاثه و
كان يبدو حريصين جدا على الانسحاب قبل ان
تكتشف امورهم ولكن عندما كانوا يستقلون
مركباتهم لمغادره المنطقه تم اعلان حاله
الاستنثار في مغيم جنين واكتشفت المقاومه
التي اطقت النار عليهم الا انهم كانوا
اجهزوا ونفذوا عمليتهم وانسحبوا
باتجاه مداخل جنين الرئيسيه حيث كانت
تحتشد قوه كبيره من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي كان نفد محمد فجرى امس
عمليه كبيره في مخيم ومدينه جنين الان
تسلل كما كان متوقعا في ظل الفشل المستمر
في الوصول للمقاومه وتنفيد عمليات ضدها
تسلل كما كان متوف عنزي مدني وارتكب هذه
الجريمه التي فجرت ودود فعل غاضبه الان
هنا كما نشاهد هنالك صص وغضب واستنكار لذه
العمليه التي تاتي لترفع عدد الشهداء
بمحافظه بنين الى 86 شهيدا منذ
عمليه الوفان الاطى شااهد عيان ابلغني
الان ان الوحدات الخاصه حضرت بعده مركبات
فلسطينيه قامت باخفاء المركبات في محيط
المستشفى في منطقه لا يمكن لاحد ان
يلاحظها ثم تسللت على دفعتين وتمكنت من
الوصول حيث لا يوجد في هذا الوقت من
الصباح اي احد
في الان الان تص ايضا ان هنالك تحرك
لدوريات الاحتلال حول جنين في منطقه قريبه
لا يمكن معرفه كانوا سياتون او سيداون
جنين ولكن الان هنالك تحرك لدوريات
الاحتلال من معبر وحاجز دوتان العسكري الى
جنوب الغرب من جنين الان الجميع بانتظار
موقف وتصريح من المستشفى حول ما حدث
حاولنا الدخول الى غرفتهم لكنها مغلقه
وبالتالي الان استنفار لدى المقاومه
وتجهيزات لتشييع جسامين الشهداء خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه نذكر ان بين
الشهداء شقيقين و اي كان الاول جريح وهو
مقعد والثاني كان يساعده ويرعاه والثالث
هو مقاوم الثلاثه كما فنا مصادر المقاومه
هم مقاومين وينتمون الى كتيب الجين وكتائب
القسام ق معنا علي سمودي من مستشفى ابن
سينا في جنين شكرا على هذه التفاصيل نعود
اليك خلال هذه التغطيه المستمره لمعرفه
مزيد من التفاصيل وفي انتظار بيان رسمي من
المستشفى مثل ما ذكرت